we have been looking at integrals and
that kind of thing and you guys know
that there's lots of ways to look at an
integral that is seemingly impossible to
work with it and you can we've got we've
been learning a variety of tricks that
take things which look impossible and
okay now I said before extension one
extension extension one could get this
question and would be fine with it so
think about the sort of tools in your
toolbox from extension one if you've got
this question what kinds of things is an
extension wants to do with is an
extension what student expected to do
integration by parts no are they
expected to do partial fractions no they
expected to well it's not all that much
what could an extension was didn't do
this you can do some kind of
substitution couldn't you or you could
do some work with identities here in
fact those are the two main things we
were looking at before ways that you can
get recurrence relations without
integration by parts trig identities and
substitution were the two ways that you
do it okay so what identity might help
us here well what I look at is I see
that cos x and I see that it causes me
issues right so I wonder can I turn it
into anything else that might be more
useful right now I think I can use
double angle excuse me excuse me I think
I can use double angle formulas here
right it doesn't look like I can but I
can write close to X I know you can give
me the standard form right but I want it
all in terms of clauses because that's
what I've got no signs in the picture so
what is this equal to 2 coz squared X
minus 1 right good okay and that's
double angle I don't have a cos 2x do I
have a close X Bobby angle what are you
going to get on the right-hand side to
close squared
all for the angles are hard out there so
I'm getting exon to here is that okay
you contend with that all right I'm
going to stick it in this here this is
the U of 1 over 1 plus 2 cos squared
minus 1 with respect to X so far so good
this is a particularly good choice it's
one of the reasons why I went there
because these ones are going to cancel
right so I'm getting one on two clothes
squared DX right now clothes squared I
don't have many options with that
because that's what ended up with it but
it's on the denominator isn't it so how
else could I rewrite this I can write
this pot as sick in terms of sec color
this would be a ha
SEC squared yep
can we do it now this is just standard
chain rule isn't it the derivative is
sorry yeah what I've got in here the
integrand is SEC squared so I'm
expecting to get tan there's X onto but
conveniently I have 1/2 right there
which is why we've got from chain rule
right so therefore that's just 10 does
it once it hard was it and you were
looking at it it's so much difficulty
now this interests me okay when you have
a look at it like I said this is this is
a characteristically 3 unit kind of
technique to use a 3 in approach right
and it falls out very nicely and nearly
there's no complicated we do
substitution involved it's quite
straightforward
okay and yet it still eluded you